so first of all I would like to thank
the organizers for inviting me is a
great place I want to describe some
modest recent contributions towards
understanding the complexity of this
hissing partition function so first i
will quickly go through background then
i will mention a little by the additive
determinants l complexity and then some
news newer things which is matching
parity and then i will so this are kind
of let's say an negative towards
negative feelings and then product
formulas which preps are somehow more
towards a positive something but can be
eventually done I saw a background I
will I will well graph is just a pair of
vertices the year is a graph an example
actually I can prevent right so at the
edge card is given so I will speak about
hcards most of the talks so for each set
of so each card is a set of edges which
set of edges so that there is a set set
of vertices so that this eep rhyming set
of edges going out so for instance from
this set V prime 1 2 & 3 go out they
that's an example of each card and the
program to calc max card problem is
given a graph find the edge card with
maximum number of edges is an
np-complete problem and while so is even
other the weighted version is also on
there is a simple version actually so
when all weights are non positive
because then it's min cut and it's
polygamy then I will loose peak about
even sets so ascetics set of edges even
if all the grease are even so here are
all even sets of this graph so it's
empty set is even and then these two
triangles and the square is also even
the degree is here degree 3 and then I
will speak about perfect matchings
perfect matching well everybody that was
every day many times he is so everybody
knows
and I will speak about well is this
enumeration so i will speak a lot about
generating functions so in a generating
function so I so I will associate
variable to each edge and generating
function of cards is just this multi
variable polynomial and button typically
we substitute for variables so if there
is a weight on edges then you just
replace variable excite by Y to weight
of a chai so then you will get a
function in one variable Y so if Q is a
set of integers then you will have
Lauren polynomial and well I will not
explain it here but this function this
generating function of H cards is
equivalent to using partition function
so I will literally when speaking about
using partition function i will speak
about this generating function of H
parts of the ground and then the there
is this you see this generating function
of each card is equivalent to generating
function of even sets of the same graph
where this is the this is the definition
as well is the same as generating
function of H card and this is a vaio
mcwilliams terenure for special case of
four actually it's also the thunderbird
NT rama which we heard in the professor
valiant talk so and that i will not not
explain it will not be needed during
fetal
so uh what about the complexity so now
we introduce some object the day
basically all of them can be counted in
polynomial time for planar graphs is
this which was he like this so this
workshop is a main topic of this the
starting point of a lot of research so
let me briefly say you how to do it well
if you have so let's say how to find max
card maximum even set and maximum
perfect matching when there are weights
on edges and well how to do Mac Scott
you you do you look you make geometric
duality then by do a little cuts become
even set so we want the maximum even set
in the geometric dwell then that you
transformed by fisher's construction
into maximum weighted perfect matching
and that you sold by Edmonds polynomial
algorithm so this is this will be here
later so there is a cute by Jackson
between if you have a graph H then you
can replace by each vertex bypass of
triangles and then the set of even sets
here is in by Jay natural by ejection
with the set of perfect matchings in
this graph ok so that's it and then also
there is a for Tanner graph you can one
can calculate the generating function
when the weights are bounded by a
polynomial in the size of the graph and
by exactly the same program because the
generating function of perfect matchings
is a Fafi that's the castellane Terran
and so you can also calculate the
generating function of edge card of even
set end of perfect matchings ok so
that's a background well it's a sofa
planner grass things are alright but
sir mark complete gets more complicated
for surfaces so there is so assume a
graph is embedded in surface of jeans
gee it's just fear with G handles then
so Taurus the total head is jeans one
that's from Attica one so then there is
an ax and a former which is now which is
now known known as Arfa invariant
formula and it is it was a brick
basically set by castellane then proved
independently by me and Anna Galluccio
aunt s lair and then years after C
Mazzoni and Rasheeda tamiya correct
understanding of it it is a and well as
Brittany's Branca to hear there are
sites so it's the formalize this PG
some and here is a plus/minus I fourth
of G and this is a vm so this is a food
right formula so there are there are 42
g orientations and they correspond to
quadratic forms on the surface and this
plus minus is related to earth in
variant of the quadratic phone and well
this is our thing by an arson variant
formula is beautiful it's a and it gives
the talk somehow is motivated by it or
at least the negative part so the 46 g
know so for fixed surface this gives a
weakly polynomial algorithm to calculate
the partition functions so ok so that's
good but not very practical because it
is what you would let's say the
algorithm well it's it actually was used
by in calculations with statistical
physics but but they are isaac one or
two physical review letters based
recently based on the algorithm based on
the implementation of it but there is
well you need to it's come to algorithm
is hard you need to calculate to find
orient the orientations is simple but
then you have to calculate fashions
which like determinants but with with
variables inside so that's you you can
you do it by interpolation you may not
do many calculations so it is hard
butter there is ok but let's say you at
least if you are interested in
nomination you get you get the whole
answer but assume that you are
interested only in value of Mac Scott
let's say for toroidal square grid where
the weights are 0 plus or minus one you
want max card there is no other known at
present polynomial algorithm which would
do it a site of this crazy enumeration
so that somehow the motivation for this
for the research and for the first part
of the dog is to understand this
phenomenon
so that is so for animation side that is
an indication that exceeds our four
invariant formula is optimal and it is a
result which I obtained with must bounce
some years ago it's a weed appeared in
2011 and it says that in a very
restricted but natural setting the
minimum number of fluffy ins needed to
express we always make sure to express
the generating function of even set is
for to the G ok so so it says what the
restrictive setting is that you somehow
the puffins are not of general matrices
but of matrices corresponding to
orientations of the graph right but you
and you can make arbitrary linear
combinations what are the the the answer
let's say the Terran says that you
cannot do it in smaller number than four
to the g where g is genes of the graph
ok so it for instance it gives an
enumerative characterization of genus of
the graph if enemy gives me a graph if I
a black eye well if I if I can I find
the minimum number of pathogens so that
the generating function of even sets can
be expressed as linear combination and
that is for to the G that minimum number
is 42 g which is genus of them so that
is a well so in so it's an indication
that for this enumeration arf invariant
formula is perhaps opting so it's for
instance it's important here that it's a
generating function of even sets ok it's
not for instance the it's not known that
you need exponential number if year e is
replaced by a perfect
Chinx is an open problem so if so and
why we were able to well it should the
proof is not valid involved a little bit
and it's crucially uses that even said
from a binary linear code there is a
linear algebraic structure involved
that's a crucial ingredient here and as
I said for the same thing for perfect
matchings if somehow is conjectured but
it's nobody can show that its exponent
that one its exponential number for
perfect matching and it's not actually
there are examples for perfect matchings
that it's not powerful that is there are
examples that the minimum number is six
so so it's more complicated
so then so then let's say that it's at
least an indication that for enumeration
these are invariant this may be optimum
but how about maximization so as I said
that is basically nothing so for
maximization you get this arson Varian
give formula of type 2 to the g times
polynomial in the size of the graph
right and that can one do better so
let's sum or perhaps to express this as
dimensionality for its frustration which
is the different dimensionalities Emma
in the talk of valiant is the year
dimensionality means Gino's could it be
that even the simplest embedded max card
has its complexity given by the earth
invariant firm so it's somehow extreme
negative view right so what is what is
kind of simplest and that it max card
well it is that let's say there are no
weights let's forget the weights and the
genus is just number of crossings okay
so like this so here let's say there is
case 3 3 it has genes one and it's
written it's drawn us with one crossing
many other drawings of case receive is
one close okay so this this problem
actually like playing with it are you
somehow introduced the following problem
it's here it is I could matching parity
or parity matching and it is desire it
is designed to pinpoint the complexity
of this low only locally non-planar max
card itself so you are given a graph and
now you have I can I don't know how to
do it with
wait but the weights are modest only 0
plus 1 minus 1 and some k and then in
addition you are given K pairs of edges
and you are given G pairs of edges all
right and you say that matching is good
if it has even a number of edges from
each pair okay so you can show it means
zero or two so you can think of it that
you have somehow the past you are a
graph where vertices are there this are
edges and you have this edges are the
paths or some auxiliary graph and you
want perfect matching so that is if one
word so that these vertices are covered
I say it only if you know this metroid
parity problem so that's in this in the
setting of the Metroid parity this
formulation in that setting and the
question is is there a good perfect
matching oh wait at least K that's the
that is the problem and there is a
simple algorithm to solve eight of
complexity to to the G K times
polynomial fan because you just guess
you just take any set of those pairs you
that also you delete the vertices it if
if they don't for Paris for matching
just throw that case if they form a
matching delete the edges there is the
vertices of these guys and then delete
the remaining pairs and make maximum
weight perfect matching in the rest
right and then compare the result takes
the best so that is the kind of
straightforward algorithm you just
complexity this complexity and enter
well I can show that this max card with
crossings can be reduced to the parity
matching with 2g pairs of edges so and
that is somehow i will not so one needs
to work a little bit it uses geometric
duality but it's not so surprising
because well look we are interested in
if we let's say take toroidal square
great and we are interested in edge cuts
then in the water what are the geometric
duels of edge cuts well they are even
said but not ever in the wall but not
every even set is a duel of edge card
right there they must be contracted
there's some of the evens so how an
inner well how to say this contract is
well contract ability in this in the
sense of let's say toroidal square grid
is a they it's replaced by parity
conditions so you want an even set which
let's say from this set of edges it has
even number of edges and from this set
of edges it has even number of edges so
somehow in this jail using geometric
duality on surfaces of ginos bigger than
0 the edge cards are tent into even set
with parity conditions ok and so then
just so I mean well it's just indication
where the parity comes it comes from
geometric duality on surfaces of
hydrogen and well this let's say the
frustration view of the frustration view
of the this Mac Scott embedded max card
leads to the conjecture that there is
simply no better algorithm that
algorithm disease complexity to to the G
for this so the conjecture is that if I
consider this parrot a matching I cannot
have better algorithm
then of complexity to to do G so what so
it's extremely strong the conjugate it
somehow says that if somehow that the if
even in the in the simplest embedded
settings namely that the genus equals
the crossing number the best if I want
to max card the best i can do is use
ours in very informal I cannot do better
so it's it's somehow it should be wrong
right but it's not so I tried to so let
me explain an approach which lightly
doesn't lead to a contradiction with the
conjecture and it's a so here is a
standard way to look at matching
problems it is that basically you you
make the matching policy of generating
functions perfect matchings major of
some gradual you are given a graph where
you have the craigs imaging program like
exact matching or disparity matching
what you do you construct a new graph G
prime make some substitutions for ages
so to death some more variables than one
make a generating function of perfect
matchings and do it so that some courts
oh that's a multivariable Lauren pulling
on me let's say and so you let's say you
should do it in such a way that your
problem the answer to your problem is
yes if and only if some coefficient of
this generating function is nonzero some
particular coefficient is nonzero ok and
that actually solve this problem it's a
disco efficient problem that is as
randomized algorithm to do it based on
isolation so you can do it by
calculating a Sofia so that is kind of
standard way to do this matching problem
let me do it concretely for disguise
okay so this a bit more a bit technical
so you are given the graph and you have
G pairs and then let's say so this
coding would be by a non-negative
integer matrix that somehow will the
matrix will coat the substitutions and
then what you do you to each at you
associate a monomial basically to it to
you for product of so if so your g pad
so you have G columns and then if for
the first edge you put YJ to AJ I and
for the second age you take inverse
right and then you make the subsidiary
are you here again basically you of
course we just somewhere need to be the
way to the origin wait so they're
actually here should be XE y e that to
the w ok
and then now you want to say that the
there is a parity matching of sighs at
least k if and only if there is some k
prime there be bigger or equal to K such
that the coefficient of this guy to Z to
the K prime x 1 is nonzero in the new
pollen on the day sir here you use the
crucially oh well it was not visible
okay so well if you use both of now or
none of paths clearly you get each of
each of these auxiliary variables 20
right but then there are many other
terms in this perfect matching so they
event they infect could have all zeros
but there you use the metric they use
the property of the matrix that it has
no nontrivial 0 1 minus 1 vector in the
kernel right so this if you have a
matrix with this property then it's true
okay but well and then so then still you
are you have this hard problem to save a
drag this specific coefficient is
nonzero but there is a exhalation lemma
to do it so that's so okay so then you
do it by calculating pasion so you put
some random weights a blah blah and make
fashion and that will then you look at
the code Z at the coefficient in the
fashion and if in the fafi and the
coefficient is nonzero you say yes
otherwise you say no so then the really
the complexity of this boils down to
calculate the fashion but now the fuzzy
end well it's polynomial easily
determine type expression but he it has
variables inside right so really the the
complexity of it depends on the back on
the number of variables and their
degrees and they they are given somehow
by this matrix and it turns out that
either this property requires that
actually the natural somehow baahhh
lower bound for the for the complexity
of calculating of this ruffian it's
exactly two to the G so with you let's
say I took it as if you want to do it by
interpolation so then this is a natural
number of substitutions you need and
that is unfortunate much it is at least
two to the G okay so so this is a root
indication that perhaps doing using this
coefficient problem and isolation lemma
will not give you a better way but maybe
there's other way or maybe you can use
it this isolation dilemma in more clever
way to avoid this matrices I anyway
that's the problem so I actually how
much time do I
immanence perfect so so then there is so
this was the negative part of the of the
talk and now let me say it try to like
they say at least something so the
parametric problem four paragraphs so
what's the I don't know oh but no it is
uh I did not think about it it's somehow
it should be ibi he said that it's a
good question are you yeah but I I don't
know of him I would think it should be
do-able but I know I don't know pretty
okay so so here I want to okay so it
will not be about let's say efficiency
of calculations but more about
presenting this generating function of H
cards in some way from which perhaps we
can then use some new information about
the recent model and it is basically the
goal here is to 22 writer the the this
generating function of of even sets of
this missing partition function as a
product and that why it's important
product formulation because then perhaps
you can study logarithm of it and
perhaps 11 can vanish perhaps that could
lead to some new engine so first of all
so this is a classical approach first I
think it was done it was of suggested by
Feynman in the beginning of 60s and it
is that and the word so it is that the
square of even sets partition function
can be written as a product over a
periodic law works of the sink where
minor is minus 1 is 2 rotation of this
of the Cold War so that is for planar
graph so imagine that the graph is not
only planner but embedded in the plane
so that each close work is some rotation
and then you have this formula and it is
a this is formal product this set is
infinite for it's not infinite only for
trivial drafts and the format product is
just a formal power series you look at
it in this way so it is the equalities
on the level of formal power series so
the coefficients are equal
is a basic formula in statistical
physics then there is so it's for
planner and it's somehow this formula is
a runs in parallel with 15 orientations
so this again if there is an earth
invariant formula for general graphs so
if you have a graph of genes geez and
there's a sink partition function is
linear combination of square roots of
such infinite product okay so all right
so then a natural question is whether so
that of course is similar to make
logarithm so a natural question is can
this egx g-general be written as a
single product that's what we did and
the let me say yeah but it's somehow
it's we don't know how to generalize the
base the Feynman infinite product but
it's it turns out that it's natural to
pro to generalize another way how to
express the generating function of even
such as infinite product and it is using
15 orientations okay so there is always
this interplay so for some somehow in
there is some conjecture relation of the
ceasing partition functions with quantum
field theory free fermions and there
seems to be this famous product since it
has rotations complex numbers that seems
to be successful but so here there are
it's more successful this fashion one at
least for us maybe maybe actually our
way is not the right one but it's let me
explain so what you do you Fe
ufe you make from it a generating
function of perfect matchings for using
this fissure construction right it's
planner so it's tough Ian all right so
it is so square of pasión square of this
ruffian which is square of this e is a
determinant but then the depth of this
matrix naturally right as identity plus
some other matrix by reordering indexes
of rows and columns and then use Buster
on what is busted formula so it is
exactly a way to express determinants of
i minus ad that ASA matrix as an
infinite product in fact as something
called discrete I had as Albert function
that discrete event front so well let me
just say it so if you have so it's a way
to look at a matrix is that there is a
digraph associated with it well and so
let me do it so in fact every matrix can
be looked at in this way but let me go
the other way if you have a directed
graph with no loops and weights on
arques then this critical as every
function is a product over a periodic
closed words of one minus the entries in
the matrix corresponding to edges of the
walk so if the entries are of typically
for us it would be X to the weight of
the arc then it would be product of X to
the weight of a is in the an arc of the
walk so it's even again infinite product
and bus proved that determinant of i i-
ad is equal to this function yeah it's
an expansion of determinant as infinite
so this it turns out that this is the
two-dimensional setting which we can
generalize and it's actually a long
program which are you started with a
student Ricky it's a it's about
so-and-so it it's about writing wait a
numerator of general linear code the
binary linear code as an able to study
that so the idea is this so even said
they are its cycle space of the graph
right and then so it's binary linear
code which is and you can look at the
graph as a geometric representation of
the of the linear code and it is
advantageous because for instance you
can draw a graph on surfaces and use our
thing very informal or if you are lucky
the graph is planar you just ok so it's
a useful representation so general
question a chiral question is whether
general binary linear codes have
geometric representations ok and I want
to represent not the code itself but
it's a weight a numerator and it turns
out that it's actually in a time of
ricky's which appeared recently that it
can be done for every for Alan our code
over prime fields and in fact if P is
not prime then it cannot be done there
is somehow I will not it's technically
not it fails a kind of miserably so for
time fields that is so and you can do it
by system of triangles so to represent
so for cycle spaces of gas
you need one dimensional simplicial
complexes but and for general you need
two dimensional simply you don't need to
go to higher damage it's enough to a
system of triangles and it's actually
not only for people to too but for any
prime and yeah and so you have that the
weight a numerator of your code is
easily computable from the psych wait a
numerator of the cycle space of the
system of triangles
so then this simply show complexes is
somehow easiest to understand in terms
of hyper graph so here is so and that
leads to consider instead of grass hyper
grass and then somehow naturally you
will not have determinant and permanence
but hyper determinant ok so here is kind
of setting so if you have the so besides
that something is K hypergraph in if in
each age has size K graphs are too hyper
graph they are almost disjoint if each
pair of edges intersect in involve under
tags its k / tied if there are K layers
and each hyperedge intersect each layer
exactly once and it is directed if if
the edges are ordered okay so that's
like four directed graph the the
orientation of NH means that H is
directed by it's also you say what the
first element second element so
similarly here is the direct it you take
linear order of each guy and then you
define similarly for directed graphs you
define the adjacency hyper matrix it
will be of size ok which somehow is
defining buried in the same setting as
for directed graphs we're here a is just
the directed edge
and then the there is a belt basically
one ingredient into this product
representation is at the following
theorem it says that if you have a
binary linear code with some weight then
one can construct a directed for hyper
graph d and the weight function so that
the weight a numerator of the sea is the
four-dimensional determinant of this
fall this identity plus a DZ ok so well
there is ok so this is the terminal but
is hyper is four-dimensional determined
so computationally it's hopeless it's
it's hard to calculate high determine
hands well it's easy to calculate the
terminals for 2 determinant but I urgent
to is hard ok and well it is somehow and
this proof of this theorem really
follows this fafi entering so it uses
you take the representation by by
triangles which somehow gives you a
construction of three hyper graph then
there is this fisher construction which
replace this set of triangles that also
can be done so you replaced by this
cycle space by set of perfect matchings
and and then this set of this generating
function of perfect matchings it can be
turned into the perma into this somehow
generating set of perfect matchings of
cape are tied hyper graph which is
permanent of this ss3 autograph and then
this three permanence can be turned into
four determinants and that in general
i'd say to permanence can be permanence
of general matrices can be expressed as
three determinants and in general k
permanence can be
expressed using k plus one determinant
and that's using 15 orientations so let
me just maybe that quickly say that it's
maybe two minutes or how is is it or she
are you already was supposed to finish
that it's fine sorry okay so okay so
this anyway so if you have killed us k
part I'd hypergraph its matrix you want
to calculate permanent and so it turns
out so it turns out that if it there are
K minus 1 by naturally associated k
minus 1 bipartite graphs and if each of
them is Fabian furniture if each of them
is planner then the whole matrix is
favia so it's a weak condition which
needs to see be satisfied all right and
also it means that it's much more hyper
matrices which are fashion 4k bigger
than two and that somehow issues okay
and the last ingredient is this
four-dimensional busting which I proved
thank you for your attention
come on can you go back to slide 7 I'm
die
okay and I think you also said that
there is this was the only known way to
calculate this to that apply to this as
well there was that just for but general
as far as I know there is a for let's
say concretely let's say if max cart in
toroidal square grade weights zero plus
one minus one I don't know a
combinatorial way to calculate the only
way i know is that you'd make the whole
generating function and look at the
maximum exponent there is a paper by
bravia on contracting match gate Network
not play not much get networks I did
still choose the TG time but it's a very
different approach it doesn't rely on
doing I would be very much interested in
it you did not know about so so and that
yeah it doesn't do animation locally as
the royal ass yeah so is anyway the very
well I'm very much interested in it but
let's say this is really extremely
simple combinatorial setting right so
maybe there is somehow go ten steps here
a five step up good work but i don't
know i don't know it the running time
also knows the polynomial in n which is
the number of edges you have to remove
to make it plainer two different ways
away ok i thank you why I interesting